[Musique]
et avec nous en direct pour en parler
françois chaumont si général de brigade
vous est également expert en
géostratégie bonsoir françois chauvancy
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
également charles henri gallois
président du parti génération fréq site
bonsoir charles-henri le gallois merci
d'être avec nous tout d'abord je
voudrais vous faire réagir aux
commentaires de jean yves le drian a
passablement énervé aujourd'hui cette
décision unilatérales et brutales
ressemble beaucoup à ce que faisait
monsieur trump alors outre l'aspect un
petit peu naïf il faut bien le dire à
françois chossy de cette dernière
remarque on a l'impression que notre
ministre tombe des nues perdre comme ça
56 milliards de dollars d'euros pardon
sans être au courant ça paraît assez
incroyable comment c'est possible
on peut se poser la question de savoir
comment c'est possible dans tous les cas
qu'est-ce que ça monte ça montre le
mépris que le monde anglo saxon parce
qu'il faut pas du monde anglo saxon
entre les britanniques entre les
australiens et les états unis envers la
france en particulier et pour réagir
peut-être à l'interview que vous avez
cités précédemment concernant la
position de moscou il faut différencier
dans le cas des contrats
les contrats qu'on casse pour des
raisons politiques mais pour raisons
politiques graves et des condamnations
comme c'était le cas pour l'ukraine et
la crimée là en revanche c'est pas tout
à fait ça nous sommes dans une affaire
économique et d'un seul coup la
politique grande dans cette économie
dans ce rapport économique et on se
retrouve dans une situation où on peut
se poser la question est ce qu'il vaut
mieux avoir des ennemis que des alliés
et que la nos meilleurs ennemis sont
bien nos alliés vu la position qu'ils
ont tenu avec ce contrat
effectivement la première fois qu'il ya
des tensions entre ses meilleurs ennemis
comme vous dites et ses alliés l'union
européenne déplore elle de ne pas avoir
été informée on y consulter sur ce pacte
de sécurité conclu entre les états unis
l'australie et le royaume uni justement
pour la région indo pacifique et vanelli
ces répercussions du style c'est un
camouflet ça sonne comme un camouflet
clairement charles-henri gallois pour
l'europe oui mais enfin l'europe moi je
distingue à chaque fois union européenne
d europe l'an parle bien d'une union
européenne et l'union européenne une
hypocrisie sans nom puisqu'elle a déjà
suivi le projet en indo pacifique des
états unis comme d'habitude lui
européenne un alignement complet des
états unis d'ailleurs la soumission à
l'otan est inscrit dans le marbre des
traités de l'union européenne et j'irai
même plus loin en fait moi ce qui m'a à
ce qui m'a attristé ce qui m'a désole
dans la réaction du gouvernement
français en l'occurrence de jean yves le
drian si vous avez lu le communiqué sa
première réaction plutôt que de tirer
les conséquences en fait de ce camouflet
qui est de dire que on doit avant tout
défendre l'indépendance nationale qui a
avant tout les ce que disait le général
de gaulle en matière plus de caral les
états n'ont pas d'amis ils n'ont que des
intérêts sa première réaction était dire
il faut une autonomie et européennes
sous entendant par là une autonomie en
fait de l'union européenne or il faut
revenir un petit peu en arrière dans le
dossier et si on est sérieux et qu'on
regarde le dossier vous avez vu que le
suédois saab et l'allemand
ktm est ce donc thyssen a fait une
pression aussi colossal en fait pour
torpiller cet accord donc l'union
européenne là dedans et d'une hypocrisie
sans nom puisque les allemands eux mêmes
ont agi en sous main pour torpiller cet
accord puisse qu'ils espèrent
dévaloriser d'aval groupe pour eux-mêmes
obtenir justement des désaccords futur
pour leur propre industrie et j'irai
même plus loin vous avez certainement vu
il ya un sénateur australien qui
s'appelle rex patrick qui défend les
intérêts allemands en australie et ça a
été un rouage essentiel en fait pour
faire sauter ces accords donc en fait
l'allemagne a été au coeur du dossier et
après un tel camouflet dire en gros
qu'il faudra insister sur le couple
franco allemand alors que l'allemagne à
chaque fois ne fait que défendre ses
intérêts ça montre l'aspect absolument
nullissime en fait de la stratégie la
diplomatie française qui par dogmatisme
sectaire pour l'union européenne va
vouloir pousser en fait cette défense de
l'ue européenne cette union européenne
de la défense mais l'union européenne de
la défense ce n'est rien d'autre sinon
donner toutes les technologies tout le
savoir faire français était la seule
vraie armée dans l'union européenne sans
contrepartie à l'allemagne donc plutôt
de tirer les leçons en fait de cet échec
cuisant on est parti dans une sorte de
fuite en avant vers l'union européenne
de la défense et ça c'est absolument
catastrophique pour les intérêts de la
france
généralement si ça paraît incroyablement
cynique ce qui est en train de nous
expliquer charles-henri gallois sa
première à un dîner ce soir un petit peu
tendue ici
si ces faits sont avérés n'est ce pas
oui mais je crois qu'il faut bien
dissocier cette affaire-là de l'union
européenne et de sa défense la question
n'est pas là la question est un contrat
entre la france et l'australie dans un
cadre stratégique et je crois que ce
qu'il faut retenir quand même c'est que
derrière le dos en revanche de la france
en particulier a été monté ce que vous
avez à l'écran actuellement une alliance
stratégique entre la grande bretagne les
états unis et l'australie c'est à dire
que discrètement derrière leurs alliés
ou son allié peu importe une alliance se
met en place pour nous évincer de
linteaux pacifique dans lequel nous
avons une stratégie que nous avons
d'ailleurs développé avec l'australie
donc en fait qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'en fait on veut retirer au moins la
france de cette région alors l'union
européenne n'est pas présent l'union
européenne
ne sert pas à grand chose alors certes
peut-être l'allemagne a un rôle mais
pour l'instant le sujet n'était pas là à
mon avis le sujet était bien le respect
que l'on doit à ses alliés et notamment
dans un cadre stratégique de défense de
sécurité
là en l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas
et je crois que si on doit avoir
confiance en ses alliés c'est pas comme
ça qu'on fait et on parle de bach donne
égale trump je l'avais dit sur votre
règle sur votre chaîne et quelques
semaines j'avais dit la même chose bayh
dole trept même combat c'est america
first il faut pas se faire d'illusions
nous l'avons vu en afghanistan on l'a vu
aussi en 2013 avec obama sur la frappe
sur les syriens avec quand même un vice
présidents s'appellent by donne
je crois surtout qu'il faut reprocher à
nos dirigeants français depuis de
nombreuses années une certaine je dirais
anglophilie anglo saxon i pour dire oui
les américains oui les anglais sont de
grands alliés se sont offert beaucoup de
choses avec eux et ben non elle a
peut-être on revient sur le sujet de
monsieur gallois oui effectivement il
faut penser notre autonomie stratégique
je suis d'accord avec lui ce n'est pas
ou conscient de sécurité à l'union
européenne qu'on arrivera quelque part
il faut déjà que la france donne se
donne les moyens de pouvoir agir mais
soyons concrets au mali nous avons
besoin des américains pour faire une
partie de la guerre donc il faut payer
plus pour avoir une défense plus et ne
pas compter sur des amis qui n'en sont
pas quand on a besoin d'eux justement
charles-henri galloise sur ce thème on
reviendra évidemment sur cette alliance
au pacifique mais sur ce thème il ya
beaucoup de naïveté de la part des
européens et des français en particulier
notamment sur joe biden parce que ça
fait plusieurs fois la qui se sentent un
petit peu légèrement trahi il ya eu ce
retrait d'afghanistan
voilà où ils se sont retrouvés un peu
isolé et maintenant voilà c'est fait la
cette rupture de contrat on n'attendait
pas ça de joe biden qui a certainement
dû faire pression lui aussi
oui mais c'est attendu c'est à dire que
les naïvetés en scène de la france qui
s'abîme systématiquement sur les choix
des états unis à part la guerre en irak
c'est une parenthèse mais sinon si on
prend ça dans le cadre de l'otan la
france à chaque fois complètement
alignés et la grande problématique on
l'a vu il ya eu latéral somme il ya eu
l' affaire des écoutes dont vous avez
parlé il ya évidemment les états unis le
royaume uni et l'allemagne d'ailleurs
qui avait fait pression sur la france
pour abandonner les livraisons des porte
hélicoptères mistral d'ailleurs
l'allemagne qui dans le même temps
négocié avec la russie pour pour mort
stream donc on marche sur la tête la
france là dedans et d'une naïveté
confondante et la france en fait face à
un tel camouflet devrait normalement
réagir vis-à-vis des etats-unis il ya
des choses symboliques en fait qui
aurait pu être fait pour montrer le
mécontentement on aurait pu par exemple
donner l'asile politique à des gens
comme edward snowdon comme julian
assange ou même mining sort est un
symbole fort en fait pour montrer que la
france cessé d'être alignée sur les
états unis aient cessé de subir en fait
sans rien dire parce que mes
lamentations de jean yves le drian
choisi de le dire mais c'est pathétique
parce qu'on sait très bien que ça va
être pas suivi d'effets et d'ailleurs
les américains le savent lien c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils se permettent
de le faire tout le monde s'est
finalement que la france va rentrer dans
le rang et ça c'est malheureux et c'est
le symbole d'un alignement que les
années d'une perte d'autonomie puisque
ça a été dit aussi évidemment
malheureusement la france il faut
investir massivement en défense puisque
on n'est plus capable de faire des
interventions de manière autonome et si
on veut s'émanciper de l'otan ça peut
évidemment commencer par la sortie du
commandement militaire intégré mais pour
sortir complètement de l'otan il faut
que la france soit capable d'avoir une
véritable indépendance nationale et une
autonomie stratégique ce qui n'est plus
le cas à l'heure actuelle et c'est tout
un chantier qui doit être mis en place
si la france veut redevenir la france et
ne plus dépendre des autres et ne plus
être la serpillière en fait des états
unis en tout cas pendant que la france
pleure le royaume uni lui rit ainsi que
le premier ministre australien scott
morrison on l'a entendu tout fier tout à
l'heure d'annoncer son nouveau deal
écoutez aussi donc cette réaction de
joie non dissimulée de notre ex
partenaire boris johnson le royaume uni
l'australie les etats-unis forme d'un
nouveau partenariat de défense
trilatérale qui préservera la sécurité
et la stabilité dans le monde cela
créera également des centaines d'emplois
hautement qualifiés à travers le pays
faisant avancer notre programme de mise
à niveau alors françois changeant syrien
que ça va préserver la sécurité la
stabilité dans le monde ça veut dire
quoi en gros que face à à la chine
l'alliance entre les les pays
anglo-saxons et
j'ai supérieur à l'alliance
transatlantique comme semble d'ailleurs
aussi le penser washington
malheureusement ce qu'on entend d'abord
montre que se fier aux anglais pour
prendre à terme anciens n'est pas une
bonne chose cela fait des siècles qu'on
doit pas leur faire confiance et qu'on
leur fait confiance quand même les
propos de ce politicien montre à
l'évidence que cette méfiance doit être
entretenu et qu'on peut pas faire
confiance à au monde britannique au
monde anglais maintenant oui je voulais
évoquer tout à l'heure la stratégie en
ado pacifique était une nécessité face à
la chine elle est une nécessité
maintenant si on devait en tirer des
conclusions passive ou comment tirer
quelques conclusions si les anglo saxons
veulent mais n'est assuré la sécurité de
cette zone c'est pas la peine demandée à
la fin de le faire ou de participer à
leurs opérations je dirais que s'il y
avait une action pour autant de monsieur
gallois parce que on va effectivement on
a eu un ministre qui parle qui se plaint
qu est triste et bien il faut des
actions c'est quoi l'action déjà pour
commencer nous ne participerons pas à
des alliances wade exercice dans cet
autre ado pacifique avec les anglo
saxons premier temps deuxième temps ban
nous avons aussi cents australiens à
cherbourg b reprennent l'alto dans 48
heures un pré tour on les renvoie chez
eux ça évitera finalement de
d'entretenir à une situation un petit
peu délicate il faut prendre des mesures
fortes et c'est vrai je pense que le
gouvernement devra non pas seulement
parler mais agir ici on veut parle de je
dirais de autonomie stratégie mais aussi
de souveraineté un jour je me suis
gallois sur ce point là notre
souveraineté s'exprime aussi par des
actes forts quels sont les actes forts
que le gouvernement français fera à
partir de demain ce n'est pas uniquement
en renégociant des contrats ou en ayant
des indemnités c'est qu'est ce que nous
allons faire est là depuis ce matin on
n'entend pas grand chose on se lamente
mais on n'agit pas donc il est temps
d'agir en tout cas anthony blinken
ironie du sort qui disent ce soir la
france reste un partenaire vital dans
cette région indo pacifique donc voilà
croire à qui veut vous qui êtes un
partisan du fric site charles-henri
gallois c'est le bracke cite justement
qui vient de de permettre cet accord
pour reprendre le terme jean yves le
drian d'ailleurs un coup dans le dos
alors je sais pas c'est le brésil en
dông tel en tout cas ce que cet accord
montre c'est que le brésil on nous
disait que ça allait isoler le royaume
uni du reste du monde pas du tout on
voit qu'ils font des alliances en
fonction de leurs intérêts et notamment
dans la sphère anglo saxon donc ça
c'était attendu et le royaume uni n'est
pas isolé la problématique celle que le
royaume il défend ses intérêts il en a
bien le droit mais la france devrait
défendre ses intérêts mais on voit bien
que dans cette fuite en avant qui est
l'union européenne de la défense où la
france a encore sacrifier tous
intéressants contrepartie par exemple
pour l'allemagne la france c'est tout le
contraire ne défend pas ses intérêts ou
à la rigueur ça ne me dérange pas que
les autres pays défendent leurs intérêts
c'est le sait la logique du monde la
problématique c'est que la france ne le
fait pas et c'est entre autres parce
qu'on est
perverti par ce logiciel en fait et ce
dogme de l'union européenne lui dit que
la france par grande générosité devrait
tout donner aux autres mais tous les
autres pays et les pays au sein de
l'union européenne défende avant tout
leurs intérêts et on attend normalement
d'un gouvernement attend d'un chef de
l'état qui est élu par les français qui
défendent les intérêts de la france et
des français et malheureusement on voit
que ce n'est pas le cas et il a la
volonté en fait de la france de
reprendre le contrôle d'un point de vue
de la défense mais sur tous les sujets
c'est absolument vital si on veut que la
france soit un pays qui compte au 21ème
siècle est normalement c'est la vocation
de la france est et on attend que ce
soit le cas merci beaucoup à tous les
deux charles-henri gallois françois
chauvancy d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir